foreign
what's up Bridget
hello how we doing
um I'm okay excellent how long you been
in lost well I would even ask that
question let's just go right to the call
what's up how can I help
um I'm trying to figure out how I said
stop being a people pleaser
oh
um you called the wrong guy because I
have a problem with that too I struggle
with that
um tell me how how that works in your
life
um well I was married for 13 and a half
years
and
um
the whole time I was
people pleasing I wouldn't
like I would just give in I wouldn't
even say what I wanted or what I needed
and so it got to the point where my
husband
um
started to make jokes about making me
his sugar mama
and
then he went and quit his job
and proceeded to play video games
Non-Stop
and
so I started setting boundaries with him
and he decided that he would rather be
divorced than
live with me anymore and and then he
immediately asked me if he could start
dating before we were divorced
and I told him no
but he did it anyway
and then he talked me into
giving him written permission to
continue dating his girlfriend because
she was gonna
break up with him
um
if I didn't give him permission and so I
did
and then within two weeks of our divorce
being final he started
trying to talk me into letting her meet
the kids
and I felt like it was too soon
and then
he got her a ticket to come see us and
meet the kids and
without talking to me about it first and
so I told them that we wouldn't we
wouldn't be meeting with them I have
full custody
um and legal decision making and so I
don't have to let him see him if I don't
feel like what he's going to do is right
but he started talking about taking me
back to court to
um
to get more rights and I felt like that
would hurt my kids more than meeting the
girlfriend
and
but then he started
he also started yelling at me that he
gave me everything in the divorce but
that wasn't what I wanted I wanted him
to work with me on what he should take
and so I feel like he's going to hold it
over my head for the rest of my life
and Bridget what I don't
yeah
so I don't I don't know that you're a
people pleaser you sound like somebody
who's been very wise about trying to
keep herself and her kids safe
and you're married to a manipulative
absolute jerk
who has been a selfish child and has
treated you like crap
and there's you're like well well played
well played
um I I
these kind of calls break my heart
Bridget because
there's you just laid out a pattern of
how this guy has completely crapped on
you and your kids
and the dreams you had in your life
together
and
you are probably from stimming all the
way back from me when you were a little
girl and you were made responsible for
the way mom got mad or if Dad got pissed
off it was probably Bridget's fault
Bridget you shouldn't done that now your
dad's old man
and now
somebody just ran over you with a car
and you're wondering what you did wrong
the only thing I would recommend that
you can do differently from this point
forward is to cut this guy out of your
life block him
you have a hundred percent custody
you have no reason to talk to him
the judge in New Mexico thought he was
so not good for your kids that they said
it's better for kids to not see him
then to come up with some sort of
custody arrangement
and you and I both know that judges
rarely do that unless there is some
really gnarly stuff going on
well I think mostly is because he didn't
fight me on anything like he was the one
that wanted the divorce
I was the one that had to file
I know because he's a coward and you
know what he did he went to his new
girlfriend and said my wife divorced me
that's the two he can tell that story to
everybody
he didn't even have the courage
to go through with what he did he moved
out on you and made you deal with the
legal paperwork
I don't think he did anything wrong here
I think you kept I think you kept
yourself safe
what I want you to do now is realize the
position of strength you are in
and you are not beholden to this guy
anymore
and I'll tell you as a dad and a husband
let's just say my wife chose to leave me
or I chose to leave my wife
and we ended up going through the
divorce process and she filed for a
hundred percent custody
Bridget that ain't happening on my watch
I'll spend every dime I have because I
can't breathe without my kids around
even when they're driving me crazy
I can't breathe without my kids
and I can't breathe without my wife for
that matter so this whole the whole
scenario is kind of kind of fictitious
but let me just say
even when husbands leave their wives
they don't cash out on their kids too it
just paints a picture of who this guy is
and he is not worthy of having you in
his life anymore he left you
and if he wants to take you back to
court knock his lights out
and if the judge
changes their original finding
and demands that he sees part you then
you'll live in that world
where they'll get to see their dad some
of the time
but I don't want you here's where the
people pleaser comes in no no you'll be
you won't be people pleasing you'll be
doing what the judge said
I mean like I don't know if I have the
strength to what to make that bite to
fight
I didn't see the kids like I I don't
want them to live with their dad in
their life you're uh you're imagining a
fight that hasn't even happened yet and
you're making actions in the present
tense on something that probably won't
happen in the future
if he is so much of a coward that he
wouldn't even file on you and he asked
for a permission slip for him to hook up
with somebody else we all were still
married you realize how ridiculous that
is
yes that's I mean I got I mean
it's rare that I've never heard of
something I've never heard of a written
permission slip
I mean that's insane it's obnoxious
the chances of this dude getting a
lawyer and fighting you are very small
and if he does he's gonna do it anyway
right what I want Bridget to understand
is you're in the driver's seat now and
it's a scary thing to be driving
and you're going to need some women in
your life that will Coach you and walk
alongside you
and hold your arms up in the desert when
they get tired
because it's a long slog and Las Cruces
is an unforgiving place I've been there
a lot
Eastern New Mexico is tough right
yes it's tough
and so maybe you ask yourself is this
where I want to stay is this my forever
place what kind of Life do I want to
build for me now
well that's also another thing is that
he hated it here so badly
but that's that's his excuse for giving
up the kids and not fighting that
because he couldn't live here
so he moved away cool now he's trying to
talk me into moving and I'm like I think
you just solidified my plan to die here
well done Bridget
well done or or this is just plot twist
here there's a whole other country you
can move to moving doesn't mean you have
to go with him
you can go anywhere oh well he he
basically wants me to move just anywhere
he doesn't get a vote he left you
stop giving
four boxes of farts with this dude once
listen you should not know who he's
dating
he left you you shouldn't know what her
name is where she lives and he shouldn't
know how to contact you
and at some point you may need to sell
your house and move
and put your new place under a trust so
he has no idea where you are
he laughs
yes you can
well I have to let him know when I move
I was in the legal paperwork all right
why would you need to let him know you
have a hundred percent custody
well I mean
basically what it says in the paper
work that they're going to be with him
okay that's fair so that basically said
he was I basically said yeah uncontested
dad was such a loser he didn't even man
he doesn't want to grow up yeah Dad was
such a loser he wouldn't even show up to
say I would like to see my kid so the
judge was like well crap then you can't
see him unless you one day put on big
boy pants and you decide to be a father
and then mom's gonna have to say that's
cool
yeah
here's the thing you're in a position of
strength
maybe for the first time in your life
in your you're in a very vulnerable
scary position because you're a single
mom in Eastern New Mexico and that's
tough
both and
so you're gonna have to submit and get
some people in your life that you trust
that can walk alongside you
and
you're going to have to consider career
opportunities
I'm gonna hook you up with some stuff
for that
and you're going to have to consider
choosing to change the way you interact
with the world are you in on that
because I really really what's the other
choice to go back with this with this
man child
no and have him sign more permission
slips
[Laughter]
can I go to the zoo and can I hook up
with somebody else so ridiculous
all right see so
um I want you to I I've got a
um
close mentor of mine a remarkable
counselor therapist who lives in that
Community
um I want you to hang on the line and
off air I'm going to give that that name
to you okay I want you to reach out and
tell them I sent you okay I'm not gonna
put that name on the show because I
don't want him to get blown up but I'm
gonna um send that to you and I'm gonna
send you
um a couple of different things if
you're all in are you all in
yes
I'm gonna send you a bunch of stuff but
listen if I send you all this stuff and
I pay for it
and you go crawling back to man child
and say once you put down your video
game controller will you hug me and
he'll be like I don't know let me check
my permission slip and see when Susie's
coming over if you go back
come on you can't do that okay
all right if you're in you're in all
right here's what I'm gonna send you I'm
gonna send you my friend Ken Coleman's
get clear assessment it's about it's a
it's an assessment you're going to take
online it's going to take you 15 or 20
minutes I'm gonna send you a free code
and it is going to help provide some
direction for
what is some work or career
opportunities beyond what I'm doing now
that might a be more fulfilling and B
make me a whole bunch more money so I
can take care of my family
number two I'm gonna send you his book
called The Proximity principle which is
just about man reaching out and finding
connections where you happen to be
the third thing I'm going to send you is
my first big book own your past change
your future about how do you deal out of
Ash when somebody leaves you when the
worst things have happened how do you
deal with your childhood stuff and then
move on to be a functioning adult and
I'm going to send you my brand new book
building a non-anxious life
the things you can do every day every
week every every month to create a
non-chaotic non-stressful world okay are
you in you know I'm in how about this
I'm gonna send you something else I'm
gonna send you my buddy Dave Ramsey's
Financial Peace University course to
help you get your money straightened up
I know the data on single moms and it's
scary right
well probably not scary for you because
you've been dealing you just lost a big
kid that ate a bunch of your food bunch
of Cheetos down in the basement when
he's playing video games so maybe your
money may even be better I'm going to
send you Financial Peace but you got to
watch all the lessons and go through the
courses are you are you in
yes absolutely all right I'm gonna send
you all this stuff listen
got to get some women in your life some
real life people and you got to give my
buddy a call okay and I'll tell you his
name off here
um I'm so grateful that you called I
don't think you're a people pleaser I
think you're somebody who has learned
over time to keep yourself safe
and I think you get some people in your
life and you begin to create safety
choose safety and that might mean not
responding to text messages that might
mean
um blocking people from your phone
that might mean doing all sorts of
things to create boundaries to keep you
safe
choosing Freedom you're not dragging me
around anymore I'm unhooking myself from
the back of your truck and I'm going to
start walking a moon two feet scary but
I promise you you've got the strength to
do it
and when you don't have the the strength
in those in those rare moments when
things get heavy that's what your
community is going to be for that's what
your counselor is going to be for
that's what your pastor is going to be
for it's going to be reaching out to
support people you can call this show
anytime and we'll put you through
Bridget I'm here to walk with you
I know it's a mess
you got this and we got it with you